what we figured out a few years ago is
there's 73
000 things coming at you that wants your
money
and then when you get some money because
you went to work
or because you get a lump sum or because
you sold your rental property or
whatever it is you get some money
you go i don't know which of these 73
000 do i do
how do i do this and people become
overwhelmed and they do nothing
and then they end up doing something
stupid with the money instead of
actually being intentional and having a
plan
so 20 some odd years ago almost 30 years
ago
coaching families we determined
that you needed a very specific clear
path
and we developed that over many years
in actual practice it was not
theoretical
meaning tens of thousands of families
that we walked with to develop
these highly tuned baby steps
and baby step one comes
before baby step two
it's not an accident that two is after
one
and that three is after two and that
five is after 4
and that 6 is after 5 and that 4
is before 5. these are not accidents
this is a highly developed
highly processed
series of concepts that are have proven
to
tens of millions of families in america
now
to be the shortest distance between
where you are in wealth
now you can go make up your own freaking
plan but your plan got you where you are
and so you need to decide you know you
don't need to call rachel
and anthony and christie and deloney and
me
and coleman and ask us if baby step
three
should be after baby step two it is
that's why we called it three
and you don't need to change it it you
know it's a pretty
and it doesn't really change there's
it is the shortest method to get there
shut up and do it okay tell me this do
you feel like
you've heard more of this happening in
the last
five years the last hour
the last few years versus over the last
20 because i feel like more than ever
today the culture
it's a it's it's a little bit infested
with
yeah but this is my snowflake i'm a
snowflake i'm united
but the law of gravity applies to all
snowflakes i know but i'm just saying
it did do you see it culturally like do
you think that that like do you
do you see this resistance or have you
always seen it oh it's always it's
always been
it's a natural because it's your unique
i mean people say yes
because what happens is the very
confusion of the 73 000 things you can
do with money
yeah yeah you have to bring it back to
the table continually yeah until you
actually believe
that there is logic and data
and decades and tens of millions of
lives
that have done it the right way and
gotten the positive result
until you submit yourself to the plan
you know it's like hiring a personal
trainer and he says well you probably
need to eat less yeah but i'm not going
to do that i just want to do the workout
you know well no you got to eat less fat
boy
you know that's what i'm looking in the
mirror i got a keg he's got a six-pack
why am i arguing with the six-pack boy
about nutrition
when i'm fat why am i arguing with him
he told me what to do
he i hired him i paid him to tell me
what to do
and then i've got a better plan and then
i look at my belly and go well how's
that a better plan
you know this is what ought to go
through people's head yeah
it's true it's true or the trainer says
do more lunges i'm like i don't wanna do
this
i don't like leg day i don't think i
want to do that
yeah i think i'm just going to pick out
i'm going to do my version
of your plan that works because my
version has got me where i am it's the
dumbest thing ever well it's not the
dumbest thing ever it's because
i know why because it feels good in the
moment to do what you feel like is safe
to do and stepping outside of what you
feel like is safe and doing a plan that
makes you uncomfortable because you're
having to change
that's why you know oh yeah it's comfort
zone crap yeah it is
exactly what it is but you have to
decide you know you have to decide did
your comfort zone
get you to where you are yes do you like
where you are
no then get out your
[Music]
it caused me to it caused me to lose
weight though i mean you just you know
your self-awareness is part of the
process right
oh my gosh